a street in butcher ukraine strewn with
buddies at least 20 lying on the
sidewalks and in the streets some with
the hands tied
horrible pictures from the small city
outside kiev ukrainian officials say
russian soldiers killed these civilians
but the russian side claims it's all
staged
um
similar claims were made by the russian
defense ministry or other officials so
far no evidence delivered however some
pro-russian social media users think
they have found some in this video which
was published first on april 1st they
claimed to see a hand movement by one of
the buddies on the right side of the
road
however a closer analysis by using the
negative images of the footage shows
that the moving object they claim is a
hand does not have the same color as the
body
we examined a higher resolution version
of the same video which reveals that the
moving object is in fact a raindrop on
the vehicle's windscreen and a forensic
scientist confirms this
that's not really an uh hand movement
yeah so that's only an effect of the
overlay of a drop and the person outside
so that's relatively clear and the
material also the the the resolution of
the frames are so good that you can say
that really clearly in the same video
some social media users also claim that
the side view mirror of the vehicle
shows a body sitting up after the
vehicle passes by
careful analysis of the footage shows
that the moving vehicle's mirror is in
fact distorting the reflection of the
body
the russian government also claimed that
there were no dead bodies on the streets
when the russian army left butcher
allegedly on march 30th
but newly released satellite images from
the u.s service maxa are now proving
this version of events wrong as well
these pictures were taken on march 18th
and 19th according to maxa and we can
see the bodies on the street which we
found via google maps it's called
yablonska street in the south of butcher
the new york times compared the
satellite images with video footage from
april 1st and 2nd the bodies remained in
the same location and positioned for the
duration of that time period
due to the russian propaganda there are
still a lot of people out there that are
skeptical about what happened in butcher
the best to verify what happened
is to go there
here's what dw reporter alexander
farnaman has found out in butcher
here in butcher russian soldiers stand
accused of terrible war crimes witnesses
speak of summary executions of civilians
killed at will the ukrainian government
is urging international experts to come
to butcher to investigate the
allegations they hope that what happened
here will be a turning point in the
international response to the war
at the upper end of bucha forensic
scientists arrived at this backyard to
pick up the bodies of six civilians
discovered there recently
authorities say they were not killed by
a bomb or missile but shot dead and then
set on fire
and there's more controversy about the
tragedy of bucha
this user mistrusts the reports from
butcher because of the lack of
the examination of the bodies is subject
of an investigation
but what we can say by the analysis of
the images from butcher is that there
are water bottles on the streets
there was rainfall in past weeks in
butcher which can be verified by using
weather apps
what might be a reason why there is not
a lot of blood around the bodies anymore
one claim stands out for us regarding
the horror of butcher the russian
defense ministry claimed that while
butcher was under russian control
not a single local resident has suffered
from any violent action
this claim however contradicts all
footage images and numerous witness
accounts from residence halls
so
we don't know exactly what happened in
butcher not now investigations of human
rights organizations are ongoing but
what we know is there have been death of
civilians and a lot of sorrow
have you seen more evidence of fakes and
misleading contact from the war in
ukraine
send us a mail to fact checking dw.com